it's funny I've now kind of figured it's
kind of interesting because I do know a
lot of these comedians and we've we all
know our actors or Hollywood community
I've now kind of figured it out where
they went like well I know Sarah
Silverman and Mark Ruffalo and Alyssa
Milano I know their politics you know
but I don't know Jerry Seinfeld's
politics are I don't know Jay Leno's
politics I go ahead and check the
Republican box let me put it this way so
if you showed out if there was a thing
that 20 years ago you showed up in
blackface I don't think you would get
the past that say Kimmel's gotten
because Kimmel is a big lefty now he's a
Hollywood lefty so he gets a pass right
where you are
you're more libertarian conservative or
just sort of out there so that you now
you're also self-funded so that helps
right like you're your own boss so
that's good but yeah but you wouldn't
get the past you do you agree with that
here's what I here's my take on it I
think they go where the gettin's good
so they're basically feral cats looking
for a saucer of milk and if you don't
put it out on the porch they'll kind of
keep going people don't really bother me
even though I say horrible things and
not horrible things by my definition but
by their definition yeah I do have a
picture me in blackface it's going it's
mr. t and how for Halloween it like 1985
I put it out there I'm like look listen
this isn't blackface this is mr. T
that's not blackface yeah that's a
minstrel show yeah this is me dressing
like mr. t because I'm a fan of mr. T's
so this is it's the normal thoughtful
way of dealing with this of course you
weren't doing it to mock the guy you
were doing it out of admiration and love
right and you would like to take it and
contort it and twist it into blackface
which is sort of
general generic make fun of black people
vaudeville stuff this is not that so
first things first I'm not signing off
on your definition of what I did yeah I
dressed up as mr. t mr. t is black I
went with a black face which is not
blackface it's me dressing as mr. t and
furthermore I'm not apologizing to
anybody about it
and if you talk to mr. t I bet he would
be happy that a bunch of kids dressed
like him in 1985 and said I pity the
fool ya over and over again at Halloween
parties bye mr. t cereal that's far
worse black face of mr. Jane sumed mr.
T's no I think with me then really
there's no job to remove me from per se
and then also I don't apologize and I
also the other thing is is I don't let
or I attempt not to let people create
this narrative and create this theme
which is you know you there's a picture
of you with black
it wasn't paint I actually took a shot I
took up I think I took a toilet paper
roll and burnt the end of it and then
like smeared the suet on my face but
there's a picture of you in blackface
and I go no no there's a picture of me
dressed like mr. t and they go in
blackface I go not blackface that's a
different genre
this is mr. t that's from the 40s of the
30s this is from the eighties but you
still I know I'm just a mr. t it's an
homage to the man and what do you want
me to do about I'll put every picture up
on the Internet I don't care
yeah are you kind of fascinated how it
hits like every comic no matter how sort
of vanilla they are there's a moment
it's in the movie about Seinfeld telling
this story about doing a college gig and
he does a joke about again what is it a
gay British King or something I were
French King with a loose hand and he's
and he said he did this joke and the
kids basically it's like five years ago
the kids basically you know
rown right it's like Seinfeld who I love
Jerry stand-up the shows the greatest
sitcom ever it's like I don't know any
of his political beliefs on anything
like he is so guarded what his actual
political beliefs are and he does the
silly joke about a French king's hand
and that's even too politically
incorrect for these students yeah you
know it's funny I've now kind of figured
it's kind of interesting because I do
know a lot of these comedians and we've
we all know our actors or Hollywood
community I've now kind of figured it
out where they went like well I know
Sarah Silverman and Mark Ruffalo and
Alyssa Milano I know their politics you
know but I don't know Jerry Seinfeld's
politics or I don't know Jay Leno's
politics I go and check the Republican
box because my new theory I started
thinking about and I have some insider
trading information here like how come
everyone else is out there blasting it
out from the highest mountain I mean
when you're on the left and you're not
playing it close to the vest like a
Morano
it's a Dennis Prager reference but the
the Jews of Spain who are kind of like
don't let anyone find weave if you are
if you are back in Bernie or Elizabeth
Warren or whatever and you're in the
Hollywood community you have a bullhorn
there on a mountaintop so if you really
just kind of do the reverse math like
who are the people whose politics you're
completely unaware of and you never
heard them speak a word about it
you must go hmm come I've never heard
how come I've never seen him at a rally
right women's rally or marching on or
sending a tweet out about
and here come I'm gonna do a reverse
math on that mm-hmm
so you're saying Seinfeld ain't voting
for Bernie I think the guys who you hear
nothing about yeah have a have a leaning
that's probably a little less Bernie and
probably a little more Trump do you miss
the days when not everything was so
political because that also is what this
movie is about and that politics is now
leaked into every part of society all
the time so it's like you just mentioned
Leno and it's like back in the day like
I never really liked Leno because I
didn't know what he thought about
anything and in a weird way I miss that
now like I don't watch any of those
late-night shows but every night you
when you see clips on Twitter of I can't
even think of who's the host who's the
who third foul and foul is the other way
NBC where the other guy Seth Meyers it's
like they're just railing on Trump every
like it's the same thing every night
over and over where it's so political
all the time and it's made me sort of
miss the day that Leno would just go up
there I'm a man it was just like he was
just doing this thing that was sort of
for everybody yeah I you know I think
there's an element of a sort of a
saturation point like you did one Leno
back in the day to dig into more
substantive issues or reveal a little
more of himself and and all that and Jay
who I know really well
has always realized that this is a
marathon and it's not a sprint I respect
that now I regret I was hard on him for
years when I was doing stand-up and I
regret it actually and I think he's kind
of realized that no good could come from
him I also believe I believe there's
some old-school comedians who go you're
not supposed to know me
you're supposed to know my jokes hmm
like I'm gonna let my jokes do my
talking I don't want the distraction of
you knowing Republic
they're Democrat or gay or straight or
anything like I don't want anything
bleeding into this this joke these jokes
I'm gonna lay over you but also when
people know you know when you take a
stand as a as a Patriots fan and you let
the world know you're the number one
paper event the Patriots are capable of
then spending a decade losing like you
know like why declare a major when the
next person could get voted in and this
thing could swing like the other
direction it seems like you're putting
your career needlessly in jeopardy yeah
it's kind of crazy for a comic that
truth-telling thing and the like thing
they can often just be at odds with each
other yeah I do think that many people
many comedians as you know just have a
different approach to comedy if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about comedy instead of
the nonstop yelling you get everywhere
else check out our comedy playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell